Hello world.
It's the Raj and the 100 days of ml code challenge is lighting up social media.
Right now,
machine learning is the most transformative and important technology of our
time,
whether it's helping us discover new drugs for major diseases,
fighting fraud,
generating music.
The list of applications are truly endless and in order for us as a community to
be able to make valuable contributions to the world,
we need to master this technology.
100 days of ml code is our movement.
It's a pledge to dedicate one hour of your time every single day to studying for
coding machine learning for 100 days if you need a project idea.
There's a really cool challenge on driven data.org to use AI to help predict
local epidemics of dengue fever,
a disease that affects almost half a billion people every single year.
We can literally save hundreds of millions of lives.
The challenge ends at the end of this year and I know that together we can solve
it,
but don't feel restricted.
There are many other projects out there.
Pick an industry that excites you.
Find a problem.
They have.
Locate irrelevant Dataset,
apply AI to that data set and create a solution.
I'll give a shout out to some of the wizards who successfully complete the
challenge details are in the Github.
Read me in the video description.
The more impact you make,
the better.
Good luck.